[Music]  [Applause]  I'll hold the road like this [ __ ] tight  pants and fast cars don't make you  Batman  get me the [ __ ] out of this car  why we got more time behind us than in  front please I'm gonna be running down  criminals till I'm 100 wants to sing  that song fine I'll put you on a new  team you're working with ammo now okay  ammo is a high school musical boyband  wit guns  you look great grandpa so you're that  guy there's always one right up till  there's not that's what I like teamwork  the definition of  Marcus somebody's trying to kill me who  wants to kill you I don't trust a person  that don't want to kill he'll put my  name up thanks a lot we got it Marcus we  appreciate it  the family that's the only thing that  matters so I'm not letting you go on a  suicide mission alone one last time  one last time  Oh  [Music]  when the hell are you getting all these  helicopters  oh this is my wife's car cover the front  door she knows he always knows  [Applause]  [Music]